No sai metterci
anche adulti non Vergognatevi
[Musica]
Stamattina siamo in compagnia di Cake
questo ragazzo giapponese che parla
italiano mi ha invitato stamattina ad
andare a prendere un caffè in un Pokémon
Center è fighissima questa cosa
volevi dirtelo in giapponese ma non sono
capace come stai Quindi andiamo in taxi
Let's go stiamo andando alla caffetteria
dei Pokémon è impossibile prendere la
prenotazione questa volta siamo riusciti
Allora ragazzi siamo arrivati al Pokémon
Center e siamo arrivati solo ed
esclusivamente perché Ok sa queste cose
Tra l'altro tra parentesi Volevo dirvi
che egli fa la guida turistica per gli
italiani Ovviamente vi parla giapponese
Se volete trovate il suo profilo qua
sotto se volete venire in Giappone lui è
la persona giusta
[Musica]
Io sono sono più contento di quel
bambino lo Sappilo sappiatelo ok
o no vabbè ma non ci posso credere ma è
più bello del Pokémon Center Ok le
nostre 10-55 Questi sono gli orari e
queste sono le disponibilità ovvero non
ce n'è non c'è nessuno va accanto vuol
dire che è disponibile questo solo pochi
posti questo è full
Perfetto non stavi scherzando quindi
radiotera vero sta cosa Ma poi è belli è
grossissimo ci sono tutti i Pokémon del
Pokedex Questi sono tutti i Pokémon del
Pokédex No vabbè ragazzi no ma è
incredibile È incredibile Ragazzi sto
impazzendo c'è questa questa cosa che vi
sto portando questa cosa è totale cioè
nel senso è difficilissimo entrare qua
dentro quindi penso sia un blog speciale
ok È incredibile
non so che dire
boh
Ma cosa sto vedendo Voglio comprare
tutto c'è un mio amico che mi ha chiesto
il di portarlo in sovvenire di gengar e
questo è un uno smoothie che ti portano
di gengar Adesso lo prendo e ti lasciano
il bicchiere quindi ho anche il souvenir
per il mio amico ed è un souvenir
introvabile perché si trova praticamente
solo al Pokémon caffè di Tokyo che
imprenotabile quindi mi devi 62 pizze da
quando torno a Milano Grazie ciao
Ok sul cappuccino c'è questo disegno va
bene eh Possiamo ordinarlo da qua
ordinerei un cappuccino con lui che dire
ragazzi che dire Questa è una colazione
tipica di Tokyo ed ecco il piatto umile
di Cake Cioè è una cosa incredibile ci
sono le carote a forma di Z per fare
simulare il che sta dormendo Snorlax da
donnas Buonasera
e questa Ah sì anche illuminato
pazzesco è questo qua è il smoothie di
gengar e questo qua è un souvenir che
porterò un mio amico meraviglioso Questa
è a colazione tipica dei Pokémon di
Pokémon siamo a Tokyo si vede scelgo un
Pikachu vedrai quale accostare Vinci Ok
scelgo un Pikachu tra questi questo qua
dopo
Grazie è sempre lui incredibile
[Musica]
ho vinto questi due poggiabicchieri
quali vuoi Io voglio quello bianco Ok
perfetto
il Pokémon poggia richiesto quindi si
vincono anche i poggiabicchieri nulla è
lasciato al caso qua
ragazzi Sta per arrivare una sorpresa
di quelle incredibili Non vedo l'ora
Eccolo qua
Eccolo qua c'è un gigantesco Pikachu con
il cappello
Allora è entrato Michael Jackson e di
fianco al Pokémon che fece il Pokémon
Store ovviamente c'è il programma Store
e l'entrata è la più [__] che io ho
visto finora dei Pokémon dei Pokémon so
dove sono stato Questa è l'entrata più
[__] Guardate che cacchio hanno fatto
cioè ragazze
pazzesco
È pazzesco
[Musica]
hanno vissuto troppo ama i grossissimo
Madonna
va bene e
vediamo cosa c'è dentro questo Pokémon
Store è il quarto che vedo Ma questo mi
sa che è il più figo poi non lo so Ok
Questa la voglio Va bene poi tutto il
resto faccio un reparto Pikachu va bene
fighissimo c'è la spugna per i piatti di
Pikachu penso che possiamo finire qua
ragazzi è comparso J dal nulla Ok ci ha
portato
questo è un rooftop che non dovrei
consigliare perché dovrebbe essere il
mio posto speciale perché lo sarà la
destra in avanti ma ve lo dico lo stesso
perché vi voglio bene è un rutto Perché
da solo shibuya Scramble che sarebbe la
l'incrocio di shibuya lo vedete qua e
c'è completamente tutta la vista di
Tokyo si vede tutto c'è anche lo sky 3
laggiù si vede cioè è incredibile
ragazzi cioè la vista della una donna e
si bevono i cocktail Quindi questo è un
posto Incredibile
ci ha portati Kay oggi ci ha fatto fare
un giro turistico incredibile Den è
rimasto a casa perché dorme però sono
molto contento perché abbiamo trovato
tutti questi posti che non avremmo mai
trovato da soli quindi meno male è stato
fighissimo che ragazzi siamo da
mandarache che è il posto in Giappone
più rinomato per la vendita di manga e
gadget sostanzialmente nel mondo anime e
manga e per i fan del k-pop Ecco qua le
carte dei bts c'è anche Jong Cook si
rischia così si dice così non sono
minima idea Scusatemi ragazzi ed Eccoci
arrivati al reparto Pokémon perché c'è
anche il giusto sto casino c'è anche il
reparto Pokémon e ci sono le carte in
vendita così come anche tipo da chiavara
che ci sono tutti delle carte esposte
tutte in vendita la prima serie ragazzi
è tutta qua e di Charlie saranno trovati
ma c'è un the Illusion incredibile che
non costa neanche tanto questo tipo ehm
€15 stavolta mi ha portato già in giro
Comunque sì i giapponesi le cose fanno
tanto per fare e quindi hanno fatto
questo
ragazzi Questo è un action figures
Questo è un Action Figure di Tom Holland
ma è incredibile è un Cioè sembra il
dettaglio raga È incredibile
[Musica]
si può comprare 500 mila yen sono
all'incirca 3.500 euro più o meno fa
messa male e così
Madonna cioè ci sono i peli del naso
Cioè se tu mi si vedono i peli del naso
dell'action figures
questa cosa è
Fa spavento ve lo giuro Fa spavento
incredibile e per concludere Non so se
sarà l'ultimo posto che vedremo ma i
posti che io amo di Tokyo possiamo
andare giù
è una sorta di luogo siamo usciti da un
film Questo è un live Action di Death
Note ha raggiunto è un quartiere dove si
ci sono un sacco di Store
di vestiti sta roba Non lo so Cioè anche
un sacco di Store di cibo quindi vendono
un sacco di tipo gelati avevamo preso lo
zucchero filato un po' strano poi
Infatti Eccolo qua era Ecco qua ragazzi
il negozio dello zucchero filato che
avevo visto e si chiama Totti Candy
Story
e me lo ricordavo proprio perché lo
store del Capitano e mi ero dimenticato
Ecco questo è un blog
istruttivo proprio così a Naso Sembra
effettivamente il miglior parco che io
abbia mai visto a Tokyo effettivamente
però sono appena entrato quindi Raga non
lo so sembra veramente molto molto bene
c'è anche Brian May famoso chitarrista
dei Queen Allora passiamo di qua perché
teoricamente si può passare c'è un
albero bellissimo e c'è una vista della
Madonna effettivamente Mamma mia C'è un
lago Vediamo Ah questa è una Magnolia
Japanese bigliff Magnolia grande foglia
va bene
[Musica]
Parco Sempione ho notato ragazzi non
posso fare a meno di registrare questa
cosa che le piante hanno i nomi tipo
Nuova Zelanda che non è il luogo Da cui
proviene la pianta è proprio il nome
della pianta ne sono abbastanza sicuro
perché quella dopo si chiama
Gina Lollobrigida che non è una location
il mio posto preferito attualmente sulla
terra e la vista che c'è su Kobe Questo
è il parco più bello anche in Canada
sono stato lo sapete non ho mai visto un
parco così bello mai mai
Cioè questo è veramente il parco più è
anche vero che per l'entrata cioè
una foresta Dentro il pacco
Non lo so Ragazzi comunque l'entrata di
in questo posto all'entrata costa in
realtà costa 500 Yen che sono circa
€3,50 che ci sta perché magari per la
manutenzione e tutto il resto no
i che rende il tutto un po' più privato
ok Quindi non è un parco che poi
entrarci come se niente fosse devi
pagare però cioè con una roba così ne
paga il triplo voglio dire solo per
entrare bellissimo è veramente un posto
incredibile C'è un'energia pazzesca qua
ci sono i bambini che giocano a Frisbee
fighissimo top 3 posti in Giappone in
cui sono stato parco Garden
ricordatevelo è il posto che non sapevo
spiegarmi quella tra virgolette foresta
in realtà è questo che non so tutto da
spiegare che cosa sia ma è incredibile
infine Allora ragazzi sono entrato in un
centro commerciale che mi ispirava e al
quattordicesimo piano ci sono i
ristoranti bruttini eh Vedo Buttini per
andare all'ottare un ammazza il sushi Ed
eccoci qua ragazzi che è esattamente
come è rappresentato nel menù cosa che
non succede mai qualsiasi ristorante Il
colore sembra fatto cioè Sembra finto
talmente fatto bene che Sembra finto
vediamo la giudicare dal fatto che sti
ragazzi stanno cucinando non hanno
proferito parola dal momento in cui mi
sono seduto dovrebbe essere buono uh mi
porto è arrivato cazzo è sta roba al
miso ok Alla fine ragazzi Ho speso si
vede
a 4.900 qua 4.900 Yen che sono circa 35
euro per quello che ho mangiato
soprattutto per come ho mangiato non è
un cazzo cioè nel senso un piatto così a
Milano costerebbe €80 Secondo me cioè
due piatti così di questo livello perché
era a livello non è tanto la quantità di
cibo Ma che cibo come era cucinato era
intestato incredibile Me lo ricorderò
per sempre sto posto tra l'altro sono
uscito sul terrazzo perché sto posto è
al tredicesimo piano di questo palazzo
qua e la vista è questa ecco qua a posto
Questa è una vista
Random Cioè nel senso non sono in un
palazzo in particolare Sono in un
palazzo
randomico Ok incredibile C'è anche un
Giardinetto carino dove uno può andare a
farsi due passi laggiù ci si siede si
studia si legge un libro molto figo
ragazzi siamo in un Cat Cafè bisogna
farsi silenzio perché qua si bevono i
drink e si coccolano i gatti
[Risate]
Non lo so Vorrei chiedere il nostro
maestro
mastrodri incaglio
dai professor
Cats questo che cazzo ridono quello che
cazzo sto posto ragazzi Io ho preso un
tè con dentro del Lazio ci sono i
gattini piccolissimi non si vedono cioè
un sacco di gatti sono veramente
tantissimi gatti in questo posto stasera
sapete giorno io avevo un caffè che
questo è tutto meno che caffè sono più
fan Facciamo partire con questo Sei
bellissimo
incazzatissimo perché facciamo col
papillon l'hai visto Lui è remoto tesoro
dicami Vuoi un po' di tempo che non è
proprio fatto per te questo ma neanche
per me in realtà fa veramente schifo
prego
sembra buono sai cos'è questo J plagana
c'è un test ma non so neanche da che
parte
ma è solido è tipo un gelato non lo devi
masticare Oh merda
sono riuscito a mangiarne una mi è
venuta la glicemia Ma non hai idea di
che cazzo Sì questo è solo zucchero
Ecco qua tra un minuto mi portano
all'ospedale comunque Scusate ragazzi
per mangiare qua necessita il bavaglio
Come vedete siamo tutti molto poco
abbordabili ragazzi non so cosa stiamo
mangiando partiamo da questo è un posto
dove si mangia speziato Quando tu mangi
un qualcosa di speziato come c'è un
pellecchio di speziato io muoio
pellecchia un termine tecnico abbiamo
scommesso e io alla fine ho perso la
scommessa Ve l'ho fatta a brevissimo e
ho ordinato e quello tra i più piccanti
che c'è insieme a J che lo sta mangiando
e non sta facendo una piega Però jia la
lingua damianto e non c'entra
faccio io
No ragazzi non ce la farò mai Hahaha
è terribile
No non ce la posso fare a mangiarlo una
prova No ragazzi
non si può mangiare
senti senti
io
ragazzi
Siete degli stronzi no vabbè le lettere
gli stronzi no è gestibile
ce la puoi fare tutto no cioè appena
appena piccanti
[Musica]
andiamo
e quindi ragazzi siamo comunque ho
digerito tutta quella roba piccante Ieri
sera è stato terribile è finita la
nostra permanenza a Tokyo Stiamo andando
ad Osaka dove ci muoveremo verso Kyoto
verso Kobe perché sono tutti vicino a
Osaka dove insomma puoi dare da mangiare
agli animali selvatici per strada Il
paese dei balocchi il nostro viaggio
proseguirà per il Giappone Ma la parte
di Tokyo Per adesso è finita qua quindi
nel prossimo video vedrete tutta l'altra
parte del Giappone
dell'ovest sostanzialmente quindi ci
vediamo al prossimo video quindi ragazzi
iscrivetevi al canale se il video Vi è
piaciuto lasciate un bel mi piace e noi
come sempre ci vediamo ad un prossimo
video bella ragazzi